thank you so much for joining us here at
noon I'm Heather Mills happening right
now some major traffic delays on the 15
near Lake Mead let's take a look this is
the scene earlier a cement mixer tipped
over on the freeway RTC says it happened
just before 9 30 this morning and the
backup unfortunately continues look at
that so this is a live picture of what's
going on right now it's because the
northbound 15 is down to just one lane
so they're squeezing all those cars in
and it is a tough slog there Northbound
Lanes 15 near Lake Mead so if you are
headed in that direction you got to be
prepared for a backup but if you can try
to find a different route to get to your
destination it'll save you some time